this tastes great rady I'm sorry what
[Music]
gourmet fry sauce premium dipping sauce
cause the meat sauce necessarily is it
like burger sauce oh that's real good
I love those the catchphrase which is
fries want it ketchup wants to be it
it's gotta be a lot of it's a little
decadent and there is burger sauce feels
like cake this is honestly like my
favorite sauce ever Oh everything
reindeer are dog this is reindeer no way
wait no boy oh I am so excited to eat
this is that freaky what's the other
taste things like a hot dog but more
made pretty good this is fun huh man
hope it's bit more meaty
let's kill more reindeer it's delicious
I would eat that with trifles this is a
gamey hotdog reindeers game meat I'm
game
the Elvis sandwich this is very exciting
I really love like banana and peanut
butter and bacon but the thought of them
together is a little strange do you baby
oh my god that's amazing I don't like it
alright so much confusing mouthful gonna
hide all right I get it
the texture of a banana and bacon should
never be together what a way to go in
fact I guess this is the sandwich you
want to die on Washington State
University canned cheese does it go back
you show up to my house with this I mean
yeah you can come in I have a lot of
questions when were you another fine
cheese what's going on my taste buds are
like hurting right now I could see being
drunk at 3 a.m. and coming home and just
ripping this thing open ok you show up
to my house with this you can hang out
this is really similar to like British
strum Teta yes this is what you need in
this country more often
couger gold you are golden alright and
dessert have I heard of pigs yeah that's
the thing that you say I will eat unless
you do this oh my god I wish you could
smell through the camera alright I feel
really bad for anyone that likes this
food I'm sorry I don't mean to be
and an [ __ ] about it nice to meet you
bro nice to meet you oh no I can see no
right
[Music]
Oh pickled and now it's kind of
gelatinous and a little bit gross like
here's the inside view oh my god no I
mean I can see like maybe it's an
acquired taste I'm actually really
curious to find someone that likes that
come about it listen what you just did
was inappropriate you've crossed the
line it's just so sad what's happening
over there oh yeah you don't know the
half of it
[Music]